members of the henderson community
speaking out after they say they could
have to pay thousands of dollars to
their hoa so the hoa says it is planning
to make changes in response to a new law
that will ramp up water conservation
efforts sasha loftis joins us live
tonight with more sasha
denise and brian that law would require
a lot of grass like this here in nevada
to be removed in the next four to five
years the person i spoke with today said
he's worried about any possible action
taken now that could cost he and his
neighbors a lot of money
but this is all now mature why would you
remove it david hartson walks through
the grass trees and plants lining his
sun city anthem neighborhood it's going
to
take that all away hartson says he's
concerned as those here in the villa
duplexes tell us they got word they
could each have to pay about 11 thousand
dollars to the sun city anthem
homeowners association these trees here
in these properties across the street to
rip all this out and replace it with
drought-friendly landscaping there's a
lot of people here that are retired and
they're on fixed incomes and don't have
that 11 thousand dollars hoa
representatives say this is in response
to nevada assembly bill 356 signed into
law last year it requires the removal of
any decorative grass not part of a
single family property by the end of
2026. they sent a statement that reads
in part the financial numbers given were
used to illustrate the magnitude of
project costs we do not know what the
final numbers are going to be i guess i
have a problem with this because i don't
understand why hartson says he believes
this plan goes a little too far
and he wants to make sure those who live
here have their voices heard i just hope
that a decision is made to be logical
now an hoa meeting is set for tomorrow
at 1 30 p.m for
homeowners in the villas within sun city
anthem to voice their concerns now as
for that entire hoa statement if you'd
like to see that we have its entirety on
our website eight newsnow dot com
reporting live tonight sasha loftis live
local now